you've very forcefully argued that there
is a very strong case for prosecuting
Trump from a deterrence perspective and
a retribution perspective perspective
could you walk us through
why should Libertarians be supportive of
Prosecuting Trump give us just the basic
of that case and that will pull up some
material to sort of support what you're
talking about
sure uh so
in the piece that you reference I take a
step back and ask well why do we have
criminal punishment in the first place
and there are a number of different
kinds of answers that different people
give to that question uh and indeed
Libertarians don't agree among
themselves necessarily on this just as
non-libertarians have disagreements but
the most common answers are retribution
and deterrence retribution is simply the
idea that some people deserve punishment
because they did something evil or
terrible a committing murder rape
assault theft and so on uh and uh
therefore uh we punish them because they
deserve it not because necessarily
they're a good extended consequences to
punishment but simply because it's the
right thing to do in itself in a
situation where the defendant has
committed some particularly heinous or
reprehensible Act uh then deterrence is
the idea uh that we punish people uh to
prevent others uh from committing the
same acts in the future so on this
Theory we punish the murder or the
rapist or the thief not necessarily
because they deserve it though maybe
they do uh but because punishing them
sends a signal to other potential
criminals or potential perpetrator the
same acts that you know this is what
will happen to you if you do this uh and
therefore uh you know you shouldn't do
it uh you should think twice before you
do it and hopefully you'll be deterred
from doing it I recognize not everybody
necessarily uh accepts either
retribution or deterrence and there are
some Libertarians who believe there
should be no criminal punishment at all
just as there are some left-wing people
who believe that so if you believe there
should be no criminal punishment for
anybody and you reject both the
retribution Theory and the deterrence
Theory I'm not going to suggest that you
should support Prosecuting Trump anyway
I'm gonna there you would have to
consistently say I oppose Prosecuting
Trump just like opposed Prosecuting
pretty much anybody because I don't
think there should be criminal
punishment for anyone of any kind and
similarly there are some Libertarians
who argue that the system of Criminal
Justice should be replaced uh purely by
a system of Civil Justice and if you
believe that you won't be persuaded by
the uh criminal uh prosecution arguments
against Trump either that you would face
some interesting issues about whether
Trump should face civil liability for
what he did but if you do accept uh the
ideas of Retribution or the idea of
deterrence then there is a very strong
case for prosecuting Trump for what he
did uh in his efforts to overturn the
2020 election uh through the use of
Fraud and the threat of force uh because
certainly in a democratic system one of
the most reprehensible things that any
high official can do particularly the
president is attempt to stay in power
even after he lost an election which in
this case he very clearly did and
staying in power by the use of fraud in
this case uh you know Finding fake
collectors or pressuring officials to
falsify vote counts and the like that is
very reprehensible and it goes beyond
merely just asserting that you won the
election even though you didn't this is
actually taking action through the use
of fraud to overturn it and then of
course instigating the attack on the
capital uh adds force uh to fraud the
purpose that was to disrupt the
certification of the electoral votes so
if anything is a reprehensible act for a
high official in a democracy that
deserves retribution this is a good
example uh and the same point applies to
deterrence uh that uh we it's very
important to deter High officials from
serious misconduct of various kinds is
actually more important than deterring
low-level officials or deterring private
citizens uh and given the enormous
potential benefits to a power hungry
politician of being able to stay in
power indefinitely even if you lose an
election and in fact making himself
dictator for life or at least dictator
for another four years or to like uh
it's important for her to be severe
punishment for schemes like this so as
to deter future power hungry politicians
uh from doing the same kind of thing
that Trump tried to do some of what
Trump tried to do maybe put down into
specific aspects of his personality or
the circumstances that of the 2020
election but the desire to stay in power
as long as possible is one that's not
unique to Trump it's one that many
politicians have indeed a desire for
power is one of the main reasons why
many of these people uh want to be
politicians in the first place so if
you're a Libertarian and you're
suspicious of government power uh one of
the things that you should worry about
is politicians uh who try to keep
themselves in power indefinitely even if
they lose an election democracy has many
flaws for a Libertarian perspective I've
done scholarship on many of those flaws
myself so not arguing that anything
Democratic is good but I would say
from a Libertarian perspective ready
more General liberal perspective
democracy is West bad uh than
politicians who get to stay in power
even if they lose an election because
democracy does provide some useful check
uh on the abuses of politicians even if
it's flawed and even if it does also in
some cases cause abuses as well so I
think there is a strong retribution case
for punishing Trump given the extreme
heinousness of the actions he undertook
and there is a strong deterrence case
because uh what he did is the kind of
thing that it's especially important to
deter and particularly when we're
dealing with the official who held the
most powerful office in the land if some
low-level fund he did something similar
uh the need for deterrence might be less
uh and maybe the heinousness with the
U.S as well the reprehensibility would
be less but uh would Trump uh given that
he was the president uh both retribution
and deterrence uh are particularly
significant in this case case in a way
that goes beyond even when you know
Ordinary People or low ranking officials
do something similar a more substantive
I think uh critique of the case for
prosecuting Trump comes from Jack
Goldsmith who you've engaged with in
writing before he's a former AG for
George W bush he published this op-ed in
the New York Times call entitled The
prosecution of trump may have terrible
consequences and he's making the reason
I find this more persuasive in a way is
that it's not really even trying to make
the case that Trump didn't do something
wrong or you know that he he uh you know
legal legally isn't culpable but he's
kind of taking a more pragmatic approach
and he's what he says here
also is that this is all happening
against the backdrop of perceived
unfairness in the Justice Department's
earlier investigation originating in the
Obama Administration of Mr Trump's
connections to Russia in the 2016
general election also the perceived
unfairness in the Department's treatment
of Mr Biden's son Hunter uh he goes on
these are not what aboutism points
they're in the context they're the
context in which a very large part of
the country will fairly judge the
legitimacy of the Justice Department's
election fraud prosecution of Mr Trump
now uh you know so for me there there's
an ideal in which politicians face the
same justice system as the rest of us
and then there's the reality in which
the doj and the FBI undermine the first
half of the Trump presidency with a
Russia collusion case that did not pan
out put all sorts of backdoor pressure
on social media lead up to the 2020
election to suppress content under the
guise of misinformation and then the
timing of all this is just terrible
especially with the federal case going
to trial right before super Tuesday
it all makes me more sympathetic to the
argument that even if Trump in some
Cosmic sense deserves prosecution
that there's no way it's going to do
anything then further degrade the
legitimacy of the institutions of
justice that we as Libertarians want to
have legitimacy to do things like secure
our liberties by administering Justice
what is your reaction to that Ilia so
Jack Goldsmith is a more serious and
substantial figure certainly than Matt
Whitaker who was quoted earlier and his
concerns deserve to be taken seriously
nonetheless I think he's largely wrong
the biggest thing on which he's wrong
about is he simply doesn't consider the
weighty points on the other side which
is what will happen if Trump is not
prosecuted for this stuff and is allowed
to get away scot-free first of all uh
that will incentivize other politicians
perhaps including also Trump himself to
do similar things in the future if you
can lose an election and try to stay in
power by force and fraud and it's a
freebie why not go ahead and do it and
you know the worst will happen is your
scheme will fail uh but you won't suffer
any uh punishment for it that's a
terrible set of incentives and it's
awful uh and that's a much greater risk
than any of these scenarios that um uh
Goldsmith posits second with respect to
perceptions of legitimacy he has a lot
of solicitation for the feelings of
trump supporters and their perceptions
but what about the rest of us and what
we will think about the legitimacy of
the justice system if a person is able
to get away with this kind of behavior
and this kind of criminal abuse of power
merely because he's a prominent
politician uh and his supporters are
likely to get mad if he's prosecuted and
convicted uh that will certainly degrade
uh the uh legitimacy of the justice
system in the eyes of the roughly 60 to
70 percent of the population who do know
the Trump commit uh lost the election
and who believed that he deserves
prosecution uh for uh you know his
actions at that time uh so if you're
looking at judging these things by
public perception and public reaction
and it may be that we shouldn't do that
at all but if we are going to judge that
way then we should consider the whole
public and not merely the trumpist
public uh and the rest of us matter too
and these people because of their false
perceptions should not enjoy Joy of veto
power I also dispute some of what
Goldsmith said about uh you know some of
the previous investigations in the Wake
while it is true that uh they did not
find quote unquote collusion between
Trump and Russian agents uh there was
good reason to investigate him for that
because there was a lot of evidence of
contact between Trump campaign officials
and various Russian agents the mower
report weighs this out in great detail
uh and as for Hunter Biden well In
fairness this hadn't happened yet but we
just in the last couple days I've heard
the announcement that he will in fact uh
be charged and very likely uh prosecuted
uh you can argue he should be prosecuted
more and that there's some double
standards there that could well be uh
it's nowhere near on the scale of Trump
trying to stay in power despite losing
an election and using force and fraud to
do so so the fact that officials or in
this case relatives of high government
officials can get away you know with
some smaller scale Rhymes that would not
be forgiven Ordinary People that's a bad
thing and we should criticize that uh
that in no way justifies uh letting
Trump get away with something far far
worse than anything Hunter Biden is
charged with okay but for Trump
supporters and some non-trump supporters
which I I'm not a trump supporter but it
is you you do it you do get the feeling
given
the timing of this given kind of the the
constant investigations that uh Trump
has has been under that it's the the
attitude from the beginning has been
like we're gonna do we're gonna throw
whatever we can at this guy to stop him
from you know staying in the presidency
or getting elected again
what it like just in a practical sense
what is why not let this play out
um in the political Arena rather than
in the halls of Justice uh you know that
there was the chance to impeach him
which the house did and the Senate did
not convict
um there's The Ballot Box why not just
leave it to the uh leave this in the
realm of politics
for three reasons two of them I've
already mentioned before retribution and
deterrence he deserves retribution and
we need to deter future officials from
engaging in the same kind of behavior uh
and the political process by itself
cannot do that uh especially in the case
of Retribution uh third uh it is makes
no sense to say we're going to rely
purely on to political process uh to
deal with schemes whose very purpose is
in fact to undermine that very process
the whole point of trump scheme to
overturn the 2020 election was to stay
in power even after he was to
short-circuit that process and therefore
uh the process by itself uh is not
sufficient to deal with the scheme that
if it's successful would actually
destroy that very process additional
mechanisms are needed uh to deal with
that uh and criminal prosecution while
not the only possible mechanism is an
important one that against a good chance
of being effective
what do you make of I think one of the
arguments that people sort of frequently
conflate is you know Trump has been
persecuted by you know the court system
by by people bringing you know lawsuits
against him but also that Trump has been
persecuted by much of the media and that
the The Narrative surrounding Trump has
sort of been pre-decided ever since he
uh came down that escalator and
announced his original his initial bid
for presidency there has been just a ton
of aggressive animus directed his way
and I think sometimes like I'm
sympathetic to the argument that he's
been persecuted in some ways and treated
very unfairly by much of the media but
not sympathetic to the argument that uh
that is the case in the court system I
think it is absolutely heinous what he
did in terms of attempting to uh cast
out on the legitimacy of the election
based off of very flimsy evidence I
think it's important for that evidence
to be weighed but as we discussed before
I mean you know those 60 cases that were
considered and the 30 of which were
actually judged on their merits the fact
that only one turned up any sort of
substantial evidence
um and and 29 of them did not proceed
and did not find any evidence I think is
uh super super compelling what do you
make of sort of trumpists argument that
like there has been such persecution
before all of this happened and it it
leaves such a sour taste in their mouths
where they're not totally sure that
he'll get a fair Shake do you think
there's any validity to that yeah so I
think your distinction between the
courts and the media I think is is
largely right in that when cases have
been filed against him in court he has
been uh treated fairly indeed probably
more fairly than in sort of an ordinary
person would have in some of these cases
and that for instance right now uh if an
ordinary person was charged with the
kinds of things that Trump was charged
with and then made the kinds of comments
about potential jurors that he has made
implicitly threatening them there's
likely that the ordinary person would be
in pre-trial detention rather an
out-free uh and also that at the very
least he would be required to post most
very Hefty bail was Trump for the most
part is not going to require to do and
the same thing I think is true in the
Civil system where various civil
lawsuits should be filed against him I
think would Trump as with any prominent
politician there are some claims made in
the media about him which are unfair and
untrue that said I'm not actually all
that sympathetic to the argument that
he's been persecuted by the media
overall even though there are certainly
particular media claims that have been
made any are likely wrong uh and that is
if you want to complain about people
being mean to you uh my answer in the
case of trump is uh you you reap what
you sow hey thanks for watching that
clip from our conversation with Ilya
soulman about the Trump indictments for
another clip go right here for the full
conversation click here